comme bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous ce matin sur la rd france
alors on le voit bien le chef de l'armée
abdelfattah amor l'ensemble de plus en
plus isolé est ce qu'aujourd'hui la
résolution de l'onu peu forcé justement
la junte à remettre le pouvoir aux
civils
non je n'ai pas l'impression que cette
résolution des nations-unies forcera
quoique en quoi que ce soit les militer
à remettre le pouvoir aux civils
c'est un engagement qui avait été pris
dans le cadre de la transition il
fallait qu'il y ait deux ans de gestion
par les militaires et callac au terme de
ces deux ans c'est à dire à la mi
novembre que les civils prennent le
pouvoir ils n'ont pas respecté cet
engagement au niveau de l'union
africaine et rigide condamnation au
niveau des pays partenaires il ya une
condamnation également mais ce n'est
rien de nouveau sous le soleil sont
habitués à cela et en six mois il ya eu
près de quatre coups d'état sur le
continent africain
aucune des autorités qui a fait ses
coups d'état n'a reculé en raison des
menaces qui avaient été proférées n'est
pas le conseil de sécurité ni par
l'union africaine dont je ne pense pas
qu'au niveau du soudan cela changera
quoi que ce soit il ya aussi cette
suspension des aides financières
internationales des sanctions
économiques aussi qui ont été prises
notamment par les états unis et la
banque centrale voilà est-ce que ces
mesures punitives peuvent également
dissuadé la junte
le soudan a vécu en 65 ans a connu près
de vingt ans de d'embargo depuis les
attendra d'eux avant même les athlètes
2001 le billet était déjà sous embargo
donc il est en quelque sorte habitués à
vivre sous le régime des sanctions est
d'être sûr sur des listes qui ne sont
pas favorables pour son commerce avec
l'extérieur dans une pense pas que cela
va changer grand chose et à côté de cela
il ya le fait que certains partenaires
sans accord aux côtés du soudan ils
n'ont pas condamné c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que la déclaration plutôt
édulcorée au niveau du conseil de
sécurité
et de l'autre côté financièrement les
pays du golfe comme l'arabie saoudite
par exemple qui mènent la guerre au
yémen et a le soutien du soudan dans ce
cadre-là continue de soutenir la jeune
et donc les je ne pense pas que le fait
d'avoir de nouvelles sanctions dans le
cadre de ce coup d'état modifiera le
plan des militaires à la tête du soudan
en tout cas tous les yeux sont rivés
vers la rue soudanaise puisque demain
une grande mobilisation est attendue une
mobilisation populaire pour demander
justement le retour d'un gouvernement
civil à quoi peut-on s'attendre
on peut s'attendre à une à un risque
d'escaladé au niveau des manifestations
et de la répression puisque depuis deux
semaines déjà le pays était soumis à un
régime dans lequel avait des civils qui
manifestaient pour soutenir le
gouvernement et l'association des
professionnels et une autre partie de la
foule manifestait pour soutenir les
militaires je pense que cela va
continuer et que le pays est en sous
régime d'exception la suite du coup
d'état et de la suspension des
institutions du pays
la loi sera convoquée pour manifester au
contenir les manifestations et les
velléités de manifestations qui vont se
faire jour là mais n'hésite plus à tirer
à balles réelles sur les manifestants
dont je crois qu'on va au landeron va
dans un an le soudan est une plongée
dans une crise qui va probablement durer
je sais par un nombre bien temps mais il
ya déjà une zone de turbulences dans
laquelle le pays est plongé et dont on
ne sait pas précisément quand il en
sortira alors depuis lundi on parle
d'une dizaine de morts près de 170
blessés
allier justement à cette répression
militaire est ce que ces chiffres
reflètent la réalité selon vous
difficile de le dire même en contexte
normal les chiffres du gouvernement et
ceux des associations de défense des
droits de l'homme ne concordent
généralement pas donc là encore il faut
savoir qui donne les chiffres et qu'il
est valide ce qui est certain c'est que
qui est un seulement et que mon client
n'est 162 jour des morts de trop dans un
contexte de lutte pour la défense des
droits de l'homme et de la démocratie
dernière question à l'initiative de ce
putsch militaire le général
albert ron qui a d'ailleurs justifié ce
coup d'état par des risques de guerre
civile qui menace le payeur aujourd'hui
on voit bien que voilà les affrontements
entre militaires et manifestants on
dénombre déjà plus d'une dizaine de
morts et beaucoup de blessés alors
comment interpréter un petit peu ce
cette explication en tout cas du général
soudanais
le général est en train de dire ce qui
de mon point de vue valide ce coup
d'état et donne l'impression que les
militaires ne vont pas céder à la
pression c'est qu'il est un roc les
questions de sécurité sécurité
intérieure d'abord mais sécurité
extérieure aussi parce que le soudan est
bordée de pays qui sont en crise mais
également deux pays qui lui font
confiance comme l'egypte et à une
relation quasi
ombilical entre les deux armées celles
du soudan et celle de l'egypte le
processus qui a permis aux militaires de
revenir aux affaires en egypte est à peu
près le même qui est en train de prendre
cours aujourd'hui au soudan et l'on
l'invocation qui sera la première sera
la situation aux frontières du soudan de
la citation par exemple en libye la
situation au sud soudan et dans une
moindre mesure la situation au tchad et
donc sur ces différents points là la
ligne lula le soudan et
son tuteur l'egypte sont à peu près sur
la même ligne et vu que les deux pays
sont dirigés par les militaires et ils
ont le soutien également dû de l'arabie
saoudite je pense que les deux pays
feront francs pour expliquer par les
risques de débordement sur le plan
sécuritaire nationale et puis les
risques surtout auquel le pays
s'exposerait c'est la situation à
l'intérieur des frontières se dégrader
l'exposition au désordre aux frontières
de ce pays là donc là ce sont les
justifications de mon point de vue que
donnent les militaires pour la sécurité
du pays et pour l'intérêt supérieur de
l'état donc on rendait encore une fois
la menace terroriste ou simplement en
fait absolument merci beaucoup en tout
cas à louis keumayou d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président du club de l'information
africaine